foreign
Athens not Greece Georgia what's up will
what's going on you never heard that
joke before have you I'm incredible
definitely I've never heard that one
before
uh my friends call me Chappelle Junior
nobody calls me that actually what's up
dude
hey so I've got a question
um and I'm just gonna straight shoot it
so how do I turn off anxiety alarms
after a season of trauma and then kind
of the second part to that is how do I
better manage trauma next time around if
it's cool I'd like to give you give you
some context of that and just not have a
question yeah for sure
so my wife so I'm 25 and my wife's 26 we
were married in June of 2021
um and so we got married and it was it
was awesome and then we uh went on our
honeymoon had a great time we came back
to kind of start our life
um and then two months after we got back
uh I got a call from My Wife and she was
in tears and she had to leave work
because she was having some some
incredible back pain
um and so after some doctor's visits
um we found out that she had actually
hurt her spine when she was younger but
it wasn't that bad but she works at a
vet's office and so she was lifting some
animals and when she did that it ended
up fracturing her spine
um and so for that entire fall we were
doing doctor's visits and and trying to
get with her insurance to try to solve
the problem but slowly her spine was
slipping more and more and so it was
causing her more and more pain and so by
the time got to January she was starting
to lose feeling in her legs she couldn't
walk anymore and it just it got
progressively worse luckily we got
surgery
um in that February of last year and
after the surgery uh it they were able
to secure her spine she had a great
prognosis but the doctors were saying
that it was going to be about eight
months for her to recover back to normal
um and so during those eight months you
know I had to kind of help her do things
like going to the bathroom and taking a
shower and cooking her food and
um and just just kind of being a
caretaker and taking care of her while
she couldn't work so we didn't have her
income anymore I'm a full-time student
and I work full-time I had both of those
going on
um and just kind of I just took care of
her and and just tried to meet her needs
during that time and then
um you know we actually so now where
she's recovered a lot and she's able to
get back to kind of a normal life she's
been able to go back to work and she
like we're kind of coming out of this
season of trauma but I was sitting in
class in January and I just had this
feeling of like oh my God I'm gonna die
like I like I'm freaking out and my
heart started racing
um and it was just full-on panic attack
and so I was in this lecture hall and I
just kind of ran out of the lecture hall
kind of like a crazy person and I was
just kind of in the hallway right when
you were saying that I was thinking
welcome to the club man welcome to the
gang you're not crazy at all man not
crazy at all yeah and so you know I
after that I just had like insane just
health anxiety just constantly in my
head of like I have this cancer and this
cancer and just kind of like what you
were talking about in the last segment I
was just like spun out on looking up
diagnosis and my wife was like you've
got to stop that it's driving you crazy
I love it and I was like you're totally
right I love I love the one recruiting
from spine surgery is telling the
healthy one dude you're gonna have to
just dial it back 30 she's like you're
fine yeah but all that to say basically
is that you know we had we had this
trauma and now we're kind of coming out
of it and it seems like we're at the
tail end of it but now my body like the
whole time I was kind of like I'm
pushing through I'm serving my wife this
is great and now my body decides to spin
out when we're when it seems like we're
recovering that's right absolutely so
here's where I want you to start well
let me say this you are one thousand
percent right where you should be
okay
right where you should be there's
nothing wrong with you you're an amazing
husband she won the lottery with you and
probably you could you would say the
same thing
um you stepped up in a tremendous time
of need what a gift and you've laid some
foundational some foundations to the
homes that you and your wife are going
to build moving forward
um that will be Legacy shifting your
kids and your grandkids are going to be
different because of what you did in the
season okay I don't want you to lose
that it was huge
the place you need to start both of you
but particularly no both of you I was
gonna say particularly you but both of
you are in the season
is grief
here's why
all grief is is the gap between what I
hoped would happen what I thought this
was going to look like in reality
endude for a long time you couldn't wait
to marry this girl right
right and y'all are gonna rock it till
the wheels came off y'all are gonna be a
dual income family you're gonna make
this much money you're gonna live in
this place you're gonna travel to these
places you can do all these stuff you're
gonna go to school and you can do this
and everything fell apart
and so there's a part of your body that
is continuing that narrative and trying
to catch up to that narrative trying to
make that narrative happen
and there's the other part of you that
is dealing with the day-to-day reality I
have to help my wife go to the bathroom
because she can't move
and what a panic attack is an anxiety
attack there's some there are some
physiological differences for this
conversation that's not really worth
digging into but
it's your body saying hey dude I'm out
if you're not gonna stop I'm stopping us
and there just came a point when school
and as you were talking here's what I
wrote down middle of a pandemic you got
married that sounds cool that means you
dated through a pandemic planned a
wedding through a pandemic awesome
um
a complete and total lack of control and
autonomy you watch somebody you love be
in so much pain they couldn't move right
right that's disorienting that's scary
and for a lot of us we've never had that
kind of scary before until we see it for
the first time when we're older and it's
disorienting
tell me if this is true after a year of
intense caretaking trying to be a good
new husband also going to school when's
the last time you started just hung out
regularly with a group of guys
yeah
uh it's it happens it's just not as
regularly as it used to be that's right
it's really easy to to be look up and
and suddenly at six months it's eight
months and you're really lonely or you
just get together and you all hang out
and you're not dude I'm not gonna get
into all of what's been going on and you
and they're like man sorry you're like
it's cool bro and then you'll have to
watching the game or eating chips and
whatever and you're down that road like
you're past the hey I'm not okay guys
and so you find yourself lonely
Financial insecurity lots of plans right
and all of a sudden this many Doctor
Bills is a lot right
you see it I mean it's just piling up
piling up
here's what I think would be really
helpful for y'all and here here's all we
want you to do
we want you to do a couple of things to
show your brain
that you're not running on fight or
flight anymore that you are in the
driver's seat
I'm in control now I'm back I'm here
and you can be in the driver's seat in
the crappiest situations and not be
anxious that's the whole idea behind a
non-anxious life but I want you to spend
some time and it'd probably be good for
her to do it too
to just write down we thought the first
year and a half of our marriage was
going to look like this and here's what
it's look like
and be real specific in real graphic I
did never thought
that I would have to wipe my wife I did
I did a lot I never thought I thought
showering would be
different than what it ended up being
there's a there's a romantic shower and
then there's a therapeutic show those
are very different experience right see
what I'm saying like I want you to be
very specific about this and if y'all
are gangsters read these letters to you
because here's the other thing she's got
a whole bunch of guilt and a whole bunch
of shame that is she should not be
carrying either right
sure has she told you she thought she
ruined the first year or she can't
believe you have to do all this stuff
right yep is that true too
yep yeah dude you see like and so listen
your body's just trying to get your
attention that things aren't okay
this is less about responding to crises
and more about hey we're not safe
financially we're not safe relationally
you're lonely you have no control of
what happens tomorrow sounding every
alarm I got
and then you are such a hard driver
you're like well I'm going to grad
school so I gotta go to class after my
full-time job after bathing my wife and
then your body's like dude we're out
it may be a season to take a semester
off
to go in there and ask for incompletes
and finish up next semester it may just
be time to give I did that multiple
times through both all three of my
graduate degrees
just took a semester off I it's too much
going on here at home or it may be a
time when you say I gotta hire some help
and get some help or maybe you see what
I'm saying but it's it's settling into
okay here's what we wanted this to be
and here's our reality that is not gonna
happen the thing that we wanted we got
to grieve it we gotta let it go and now
we got to build what comes next and it
may be that man I'd hope to have a
graduate degree but how old are you 25
25 okay what are you going to grad
school for
interior software engineering
computer saw wow you're really smart huh
I'm The Logical she is like the fun
creative like let's do everything and
just be weird and crazy and I'm gonna
let's stay in a line and do things by
the book and build blocks awesome so
that will kill you in this season
acknowledging grief for you is loosening
your grip on the Wheel
because you've clamped down on that
sucker haven't you
absolutely yeah
and dude you're too good of a guy the
world needs you
for you to die of a stroke or a heart
attack at 35 years old
right and a lot of that comes from
sitting in grief
I thought I could control everything and
come to find out I can't and that sucks
and then looking over and saying but I
do love you and I do love what we're
building together and we're going to
build something completely new
I want you to write a letter I want her
to write a letter and I want you all to
read them to each other
and then here's the second part of the
exercise I want you all to
um
I want you to write okay here's what
happens next in the next six months
that's it the next six months here's
what happens next
and hold it very very Loosely and check
in once a week check in once a month for
a little bit deeper dive
how's the six we had a plan how's it
going how's it working and she might
tell you how about we take the plan and
wad it up and use it as two ply and you
could be like that sounds great but
we're gonna just say okay here's our new
reality and then in six months we're
gonna plan a new one then we're gonna
plan a new one then we're gonna plan a
new it's gonna be an ongoing planning
season the idea that you're gonna put us
all in a spreadsheet at 25 and it's
going to roll out when you're 75. that
time is over it's not gonna work and I'm
glad you got to learn it now most of us
learn that in our 30s and 40s and then
we think like we shouldn't be married it
gets caustic you learned it young good
for you man
but I want to give your wife an
opportunity to speak her guilt and shame
that's unwarranted and you look around
the eye and say no no it's been my
life's greatest gift to be able to walk
alongside you and I want her to be able
to look at you and say I know you had a
bunch of plans and they're sideways
let's make new ones and let's do that
together we'll hang on the line we're
gonna I'm gonna send you both
um the first and the second edition of
the couples questions for humans you all
can sit around and chit chat with each
other and maybe get weird and dude again
thank you so much for being a husband
who steps up for a husband who loves his
wife and for being brave enough to tell
your story
a lot of us need to hear that
Gentlemen let's step up